good morning Hank it's Friday it's the
final day of pizza mis 2015 and what a
ride it's been we've laughed we've cried
we suited up we've learned some art
history and perhaps most importantly we
have made the acquaintance of cheese
doodles guys yeah but all good things
must end even the excitement over cheese
doodles in fact come to think of it
everything must end in this universe to
be is to not always be there actually
maybe not maybe to be is just to change
after all those cheese doodles
eventually became poop but anyway the
undefeat service also means this is the
last day you can order pizza miss merch
my face in a nebula on your torso only
available until midnight tonight along
with the rest of the pizza miss mer
check it out at dftba.com link in the
doobly-doo but if you leave Pizza miss
with no physical mementos fear not when
nerdfighter DC complained that they were
too broke to enjoy beats and miss
untapped inkwell replied Pizza vez is
just as much a state of being as it is a
consumerist holiday so true so true of
all consumerist holidays actually at
which these days is to say all holidays
but speaking of states of being you
talked about kind of personal stuff in
your video yesterday hang so I guess
I'll do the same I have a mental illness
called obsessive-compulsive disorder
which is often associated with anxiety
and depression problems I try to talk
about that sometimes because I don't
think there should be anything
embarrassing about mental illness but I
don't talk about it that much because
one it's personal and two I find it
difficult to talk about my own
experiences with chronic illness because
the central way we imagine sickness as a
thing that we must conquer and then put
behind us doesn't really apply to
chronic illness like when you go to the
store to get a card for a sick friend
you go to the get-well-soon section
right but for people living with chronic
illness it often isn't a question of
getting well soon like a guy hope some
day they cure ulcerative colitis but I
don't expect you to get well soon
instead my hope for you is that you have
a rich and full life and that you aren't
marginalized because of your illness
which is a big problem I have a theory
about this egg I don't think we humans
like to imagine our lives as random we
need human lives to be narratives that
make sense so if we can't find causation
we just create it like people get
depression because they're weak or they
get diabetes because they don't eat well
or they have heart failure because they
don't exercise all that stuff is either
totally inaccurate or overly simplistic
but we want every effect to have a cause
and when we can't find that cause we
invent one anyway hey guys you know I
have been very sick the last several
weeks as I've tried to figure out a new
medication regimen
over the years of living with my illness
I've learned a lot about how to make it
tolerable I've learned to celebrate
small successes I've learned to
encourage myself without being cruel and
most importantly I've learned that there
is hope and that when I feel like there
isn't hope my brain is lying to me but
still it is awful and after years of
relatively good health I have been
reminded in the last several weeks just
how painful and crushing this stuff can
be and that's despite my having all
kinds of advantages that make it easier
to live with an incredibly supportive
family total job flexibility an
excellent therapist and psychiatrist
money to afford medication etc most
people don't have all those resources
and that worsens any kind of illness
Hank I mentioned all this for three
reasons first to tell people who may be
living with mental illness that there is
hope that mental illness is almost
always treatable and that how you feel
when you are at your sickest is not how
you will always feel and down in the
doobly-doo you can find links to
resources that I found helpful when the
people I know and I found helpful
secondly I want to remind all of us that
what we see in videos are on Instagram
isn't the whole story like my friends
and family have known that I have been
unwell the last several weeks because it
is impossible for me to hide it from
them but it is very possible for me to
hide it with junkets and lastly to say
thanks thank you for watching these
videos and Hank thank you for the gift
of Pizza --mess which has given
structure and achievable tasks to my
life at a time when I desperately needed
them I'm starting to feel better for a
variety of reasons from medication to
exercise but the gift of pizza muss has
been surprisingly important so thank you
for being part of it Hank don't forget
to be awesome I will see you no no you
will see me on Tuesday